This is a video about a mechanic I love, a
commander card I hate, and a bizarre deck
I built out of spite. Our tale begins in 1998,
with Urza’s Saga bringing all sorts of horrendous
bullshit to the world, and also a gift—the cycling
mechanic. It’s a beautifully simple mechanic: you
can pay an alternate cost on a card and discard
it in order to draw a card. This began in simple
fashion during Urza Block, but five years later
Onslaught block added a ton of dimension to the
mechanic. Varied cycle costs, triggers attached
to cycle abilities, cycling for basic land types,
and six cards with triggered abilities when
other cards were cycled. These six were varying
power levels, with one in particular being just…
excellent, but we’ll talk about that a bit later.
Cycling has seen additional prints every
few years since, and for a simple reason:
people like this mechanic. As an alternate cost
ability it adds a lot of flexibility to cards,
which leads to interesting decisionmaking. Every
cycling card a player draws prompts the question
“is this card better than a different card plus
a small mana commitment?” This is nice in aggro
when running out of gas might be a concern,
and it’s even more useful in a control deck,
where that mana cost can be spent on the end of an
opponent’s turn, or even in response to things to
dig for answers. On top of this, since cycled
cards are discarded and go to the graveyard,
they work well with graveyard synergies, providing
a near effortless way to put cards in the yard.
And that’s only the playstyles helped out
by the mechanic innately. Remember that
cool card from Onslaught I mentioned? Astral
Slide has seen a ton of experimentation ever
since it was printed, as it synergizes with many
different cards and offers a ton of flexibility.
As a result it was kind of understood as
the core of any cycling deck before 2020.
Astral Slide decks have a super interesting
playstyle that revolves heavily around strategic
resource management, and in a way that feels
very in-line with the fundamental nature of
the mechanic. Number of cycling cards in hand
constantly dictates the strategic direction of
the deck—when you have more, you can get
bolder and set up for more daring turns,
as well as using the slide triggers more
liberally—as blocker elimination, to net
small value off of ETBs, and so forth, or casting
a cycling card normally. By contrast, when you
have fewer cycling cards in hand, each one is pure
gold. You always want to save them for protecting
a critical creature or disrupting a dangerous
play from an opponent, but if you feel the game
slipping away you can also choose to gamble that
lifeline on an endstep for a little bit of value.
In addition, mana is a super important resource
for both Astral Slide and the mechanic as a whole,
as land counts also dictate how safe you feel
playing setup pieces, and how bursty your turns
can be. A more controlling cycling deck constantly
forces a player to think probabilistically—if I
spend mana to play a spell on my turn, what are
the odds I’ll be able to handle a key threat on
my opponent’s turn if it gets played? What are
my odds of drawing an additional cycling card
or an answer off the top? How much mana would I
need to have the best chance of averting death
in a worst case scenario? These questions are
also fundamentally tied to deck construction,
since a player must always weigh the strength of a
cycling card vs the cycling cost of it. As a card,
Akroma’s Vengeance is wildly more powerful
than Winged Shepherd, but if I’m sitting
there on an opponent’s turn with four mana
open, looking down the barrel of defeat,
I know which of the two I’d rather have in
hand. In short, the cycling mechanic creates and
promotes far more textured and strategic gameplay
than the vast majority of mechanics in MTG.
With all of that deep strategic texture in mind,
let’s talk about Gavi, Nest Warden. It’s a 5 mana
2/5 who makes the first cycle each turn free,
and who creates a cat when you draw your second
card each turn. This card is strong enough to be
a natural choice for a cycling commander, and also
deathly boring. Free cycles on each turn removes
an entire dimension of the cycling mechanic,
and on top of that it highly encourages a
stable quantity of cycling—one per turn,
maybe two on an opponent’s turn sometimes. Every
cycle past that is a waste, since you have to pay
for it and you don’t even get a cute little
dino-cat, and every turn you fail to cycle is
also a waste. C’mon, it’s free real estate. This
ability and the associated incentives remove the
status of cycling cards as an important
resource to be saved and used carefully,
and also in turn leave players with a lot of
extra mana they didn’t have to plan out. What
does that mana get spent on? Well, permanents that
generate value when cards get cycled, of course.
Gavi destroys most of the cool, strategic
decision-making generally involved with
playing a cycling deck, and replaces it with
yet another do-the-thing value-pile midrange
deck. The design of most Gavi decks is such that
if you do the thing—cycling in this case—you get
an effortless mixture of card advantage
and board advantage spread out over time,
just like the other 80% of EDH decks that exist
out there. And this isn’t because Gavi players
are people who like especially boring decks—the
card is precision designed to encourage exactly
this type of gameplay, even if you build from
scratch rather than buying the precon. It’s
a betrayal on the part of Wizards of the Coast
of everything cool about the cycling mechanic,
and it creates totally predictable
gameplay—well, except for one thing.
You see, the other thing that Gavi incentivizes
is cards with high cycling costs. This is
maybe the one thing about the card that’s not
dead-boring, but not really in a good way? Okay,
so this incentivization is most relevant for
one specific cycle of cards from Scourge,
and since Gavi doesn’t pay the
bonus cost of Decree of Justice,
it’s actually mainly relevant for two cards.
The first is Decree of Silence. Big whoop,
it’s a free counterspell you’ll have sometimes.
Not much to say here. The other is Decree of
Annihilation. I’ll here deliver a hot take—nuking
lands is maybe okay, maybe pretty cool,
if your playgroup is down for that, and also if
you actually have a way of ending the game pretty
soon after using that wild swing of momentum.
But nothing else about Gavi really promotes
that sort of deck-style. More likely, you’ll
keep slowly getting cats, everybody’s manabase
will gradually recover, and congratulations:
you’ve just doubled the length of this game.
Gavi into Decree of Annihilation, while certainly
unusual, still kinda fails to be interesting.
So, we have here this pretty bland commander,
and if you ask an EDH player what they think
about cycling, she’s what they think of. This cool
mechanic with a rich history and tons of synergy
potential, reduced down to yet another value pile
commander. Now, to any Gavi players out there,
I want to say: this is not an attack on you, and
Gavi is more interesting than a lot of commanders
out there. There are still some interesting
synergies and fun instant speed plays to be had
piloting a Gavi deck. I don’t hate it because it’s
a uniquely bad design—it’s not—I hate it because
it’s a total betrayal of one of my favorite
mechanics. And this isn’t just about Gavi,
either. Wizards has a habit of printing what
I’ll call “designer commanders,” which I here
use to mean commanders that take a particular
mechanic and fully dedicate themselves to it,
dictating a very specific and often very
boring type of deck based around that mechanic.
Another example is Eligeth, Crossroads
Augur—taking scry, a neat top of library
manipulation mechanic, and literally just
replacing it with value in a way that
doesn’t synergize with anything related to the
original mechanic. Cool. These commanders push
players toward less interesting decks, and their
specificity causes them to offer a narrow range of
possible decks to be built. A popular typographic
format for this sort of commander is one with two
lines of text, one that says “whenever X happens,
Y happens” and another that says “whenever enough
Ys happen, a Z happens”. This is a template that
builds its own deck—you run cards that do X and Y,
and maybe even some Z payoff if you’re feeling
nutty. Some people might enjoy this type of deck,
and to those people I have to say: that’s great!
There are certainly people out there who want
these kinds of cards—newer players, people who
don’t want to spend too long on deckbuilding,
or people who like to make unexpected versions
of seemingly straightforward commanders,
and I think it’s cool that Wizards of
the Coast has given them lots of options
to work with. But if you want to try out an
alternative form of commander deck building,
I’m here to offer you a vision of what could be.
For the rest of this video, I’m going to talk
about how I took one look at Gavi, and then turned
around and built a truly bizarre cycling deck.
It started with me absentmindedly cruising through
random Onslaught cards looking for deck ideas,
as one does, and as expected I saw Astral Slide,
but also another enchantment I wasn’t familiar
with—Overbooked Cemetery. These seem kinda
neat together, right? One promotes cycling,
the other works well after I cycle creatures
into the graveyard? With these in my pocket I
decided to include blue as well, since it’s a
very useful color for both cycling and instant
speed shenanigans, and I started shopping around
for a commander in Esper colors. My hope was to
find a commander that could be a flexible value
engine when I flickered cards with Astral Slide,
and this was my shortlist. Eventually, I
decided all of them were either too generic,
too niche, or not the right vibe,
all except good ol’ Sharuum.
With my commander selected, I set some healthy
ground rules: no Sculpting Steel type combos,
and a $100 budget. I’m not building a high-power
Sharuum deck, I’m building an Astral Slide deck.
A good place to start is always wincons, and one
that leapt out immediately was Magister Sphinx,
which combined with Sharuum can one-shot a
player. Sharuum’s nature as a reanimation
tool means that a beatdown suite
with a number of big flying artifact
creatures is likely to be a good bet at
hundred-dollar-cycling-deck power levels,
and will hopefully offer enough beef to win even
when Magister Sphinx isn’t available. However,
this beatdown step will likely be tricky unless
I’m mostly stabilized against hate and attacks,
which can be accomplished through
my core card of Astral Slide.
The card offers so many use cases—it’s
a reanimation engine with Sharuum,
it can be a value, removal, ramp, or lifegain
engine with other artifact creatures,
and that’s to say nothing of the built-in
protection and disruption utility of the
card. Since Astral Slide is so key to the
deck and I can only run two in the deck,
enchantment tutors were a must, so I started
out with Idyllic Tutor, and eventually settled
on Zur as my other tutor. His wizard tag is oddly
important, as WotC has printed two Wizardcycling
cards—basically instant speed wizard tutors
that count as a cycle. Out of these strange
cards organically grew a toolbox that expanded as
I found new hurdles my deck needed to overcome.
Wizardcycling grabs a tutor for slide, a tutor for
my top end boys, a recursion spell for my slides,
and a stifle effect that’s also an extra
cycle for my big turns. A mixture of tutoring,
discard outlets, and my recursion spell commander
means that my deck’s key pieces generally get into
play mana-efficiently. The deck does a great
job scratching my itch to play a complex and
strategic deck, and it does so at a middling power
level that feels good in quite a lot of pools.
A key takeaway from this deckbuilding
process for me was the strength of flexible,
ground up deck construction. By starting with
a mechanic and a couple key cards and selecting
a commander afterward, my deck ended up with a
foundation that includes the commander but doesn’t
wholly consist of the commander. It’s built to
follow general best practices for cycling decks,
and though it does include the occasional stormy
element or value engine, each of these pieces are
intentional, and most of them are tutorable if
I decide that’s what a given situation demands.
The most important thing I prefer to avoid is
having the entire deck stand on the shoulders of
the commander, at least not unless you’re ready
for that sort of responsibility. I could have
made the commander Zur, but then the issue of not
having a consistent value source combined with Zur
being a removal magnet would have rapidly turned
my deck into one more Zur than Astral Slide,
as draw enchantments and protection spells gobble
up my deck space. It’s good to keep in mind the
sort of deckbuilding incentives a given commander
pushes onto you, as even one that seems like a
good idea on paper might make your deck make
a turn that isn’t what you were looking for.
If I was to wrap this up in a bow, I’d go
with this: when you’re building a deck,
figure out what the deck wants to do, and try to
turn that into a somewhat focused plan. Accept
that you won’t nail the first version of the
deck, and that there’s room to adapt as you
encounter further problems. I’d say there
are four key versions of any single deck:
the first principles version in your brain,
the draft version after you actually hammer
out a 100 card list, the streamlined version
completed after you solo playtest a bit,
and the “final” version completed after you
play it against other people for a while.
Each of these steps will solve a different set of
problems that the deck has, and that’s a strength.